welcome back to cbs mornings here at 7
30. the u.s and south korea are holding
joint military exercises on the korean
peninsula their largest in years and
these drills will continue through
september first
they follow a record number of missiles
fire fired in international waters by
north korea this year and our partners
at the bbc were given rare access at
this time to a joint control center for
the u.s and south korean militaries so
here's gene mckenzie with more from
seoul
deep underground an american and a south
korean colonel watch north korea i'm
learning but it's difficult to get it
right in this classified bunker outside
seoul the two militaries work together
to defend against a north korean attack
this is the only place in korea where
u.s forces and south korean forces sit
side by side and using all this
information they can detect almost
immediately if north korea launches a
weapon between um his great english and
my terrible korean we can usually muddle
through a lot of different things and
get to a decision quickly
the threat from north korea is
increasing its missiles are becoming
more dangerous it's rhetoric more fiery
so these war games from five years ago
are back as the u.s and south korea
practice how to fight their common enemy
using aircraft warships and tanks
i can't do it in a classroom i can't do
it on a chalkboard i have to give them
the most intense environment that we can
create and this is that environment
sticking out here this is our gun barrel
fighter pilot captain abby walters will
train from the sky
it's really important for us to train
together with the south koreans the
communication flow is much better in the
air if you've practiced it multiple
times
so it can go quicker which helps us get
more effects down and just be more
efficient and deadly in our job
north korea sees these drills as a
rehearsal for an invasion there is
concern it could retaliate in this
recent speech kim jong-un warned they
could end in war
they might have the appearance of war
but the u.s and south korea insist these
drills are defensive in part a show of
strength to convince north korea never
to use its weapons
especially as it works to develop ones
that can evade missile defenses
so it's your first time at osan
lieutenant general scott plies is the
deputy head of the u.s forces career
i have absolutely no worries whatsoever
that north korean missiles
have a way of defeating our
capabilities here on the peninsula but
they are making progress
and so are we
intelligence suggests north korea is on
the cusp of testing its first nuclear
weapon in five years
south korea says it shouldn't be blamed
if these drills provide its ammunition
since north korea know that this one is
a defensive one and they wanted to
utilize
this joint military drill for their own
political purpose i think that the joint
military drill is a one excuse for north
korea
to do that kind of military provocation
war games may well provoke north korea
but faced with an increasingly
formidable enemy these forces believe
they have no choice but to prepare gene
mckenzie bbc news for cbs mornings in
seoul
thanks to gene and our partners at the
bbc in london